hello and welcome to my mini series
regarding how to use SFTP in python
together to do pretty awesome stuff so
not only can we use this to just simply
upload and download files and just think
of it that way we can actually wind up
using it as a sort of back-end to a
website so for example like I use my own
computers and my own servers here to do
a lot of the grunt work for my websites
and XCOM most of that like processing
and bandwidth and even storage is all
cheaper like if you just buy it yourself
or if you buy an insane bulk but like
for most people running websites you're
paying a pretty high premium for that
hardware obviously you're getting the
benefit of not having to worry about
maintenance and all this but at the end
of the day if you're running a website
that requires like mid-range performance
it makes sense that you would just do
some of this on your own if you can
anyway so I have my computer's comedic
communicating with the Centex server to
transfer files run various jobs tasks
and more and then other examples like a
lot of hosting websites are going to
charge you if they even offer it at all
a good amount of money to run scheduled
backups of your data and whereas like if
you have SFTP or SSH access you can do
it yourself with a command but if you
don't if you don't have Python or
somewhat something else if you could run
like in a cron maybe but then the files
would still remain on the server so it's
a part of like the reason I don't really
like that is if you run it back up yeah
the whole idea of backing it up is just
in case something happened to the server
it's if you back it up on the server not
always that like the best backup so you
want it in your hands anyway so so you
can use it for that as well but
regardless or whatever you want to use
it for it's definitely just just really
helpful it's an empowering skill to have
for pretty much anybody running a
website so in order to do this we're
going to need a few things and we should
also know exactly kind of like what
we're aiming to achieve here so those
tutorial is going to be a mini series
that deals with s
FTP so SFTP is just FTP or File Transfer
Protocol with an S or secure added to it
so natively FTP like if you have like an
FTP like maybe like FileZilla or
something like this natively that's like
really just insecure you really
shouldn't you shouldn't be using FTP
SFTP adds a layer of encryption to kind
of put it closer to the amount of
security of SSH but as far as I know I
believe SFTP is still less secure but
you've got encryption now so it's not as
big of a deal so and we're going to be
using SFTP it's still really really
basic and simple to use and that layer
of encryption is added through a module
called PI crypto luckily for you
everything with PI crypto and the actual
encryption and decryption process right
everything is done behind the scenes so
so like you won't have to learn how to
do encryption within Python but if you
are actually interested in doing
encryption with Python I do also have a
tutorial on PI crypto showing you how to
encrypt and decrypt so if you're
interested in that I do have video on
that but we're not going to be covering
that here so either way we need to get
the modules and go ahead get started so
what you're going to need is there's
going to three modules that you need you
need high crypto param eco and PI SFTP
and you're going to want to download
them in that order because Pi cryptos
dependency of param eco and padam ego is
a dependency of pi SFTP so you want to
download them and install in that order
and also as with any of the downloads
you're going to want to be sure that you
download the correct bit version for
your installation python and i think by
this time and for this tutorial series
i'm going to go ahead and assume that
you all know how to download and install
things in python just kind of assume
that if you're interested in python it
transfer data between servers you
probably know what you're doing at this
point as far as installing things so i'm
going to put the download links in the
description just to save you guys some
time
man I'm a nice guy and again just just
remember whether you're 32 or 64-bit and
then also I'll put the like PI crypto
for example doesn't come natively 64-bit
and neither does pair amico I'm not
positive that you'll actually need a
64-bit version of paramiku but I include
that just in case but you will for sure
need the 64-bit version of crypto so
definitely download that one anyway the
rest is there and then also I'll link
you guys to the PI SF PI SFTP module so
once you've downloaded all those things
make sure you can go to your interpreter
let me bring up my interpreter let's see
if I have one and make sure you can do
the following PI crypto will actually be
just an import capital C YPT o as long
as you get nowhere as you install that
one correctly next one we want to do is
import about amigo and that one went
we'll and then finally import PI SFTP
the only one that doesn't it's not the
same name as the module is crypto but
anyway so as long as you can import all
three of these then you're good you've
installed everything and you're ready to
proceed to the next video if you have
any issues with the installation or
maybe one of those links I gave you is
now dead please leave a comment below if
you need help with anything I'm always
willing now so with that include the
video as always thanks for watching
thanks for the support with
subscriptions I just hit thousand
subscriptions by the way that's free and
awesome until next time